je dis que finalement les avantages du
succès c'était de pouvoir choisir les
émissions qu'on faisait quand je te
remercie d'être là parce que j'imagine
que cet appareil on recevrait j'aime pas
beaucoup ça gêne pas beaucoup ça l'était
le succès tant en miroir un petit peu
défendons et on peut bien amusant je
sais c'est pas très bien on prend la
tête a dit que quand on était dans une
telle est en train de vendre indice de
faire la promo d'un 10 on avait
l'impression un peu d'être un vrp que sa
camionnette garée en poussines moi c'est
sûr que c'est incontournable
ou quand un nouvel album son orgie de
faire connaître aux fins de faire
partager le plaisir quand ils veulent
faire avec certains des moyens de
pouvoir le faire connaître quoi cette
tournée tu crois qu'être star c'est se
faire rare probablement en tout cas est
vif et éviter de lasser les gens ouais
parce que c'est un truc que le système
un petit peu mon le lien est et qu'on
voit trop les gens et qu'on est là c'est
très trop vite
donc ouais t'as peur de me faire exclure
vraiment des coins où est plus en plus
ça ne correspond pas vraiment way le
discret comme mec je préfère porter un
clip avec les géniales qui sort à un
médecin mais qu'on va pas dire son nom
parce que il est polonais ils viennent
lui a failli 6 à bensberg dinho rybinski
sa vie d'un génie sextant
c'est un mec il
qui est le seul en fait à utiliser un
système nouveau au monde qui permet
d'avoir plusieurs générations d'image
mais sans perdre en qualité
donc ça lui permet toutes les fantaisies
possible au fond lui doit le tube de
lennon qui est pour marcher devant nous
non trop celui de lou reed
là il fait plein de cris pour plein de
gens qui l'avaient dit j'arrête de faire
des clips qu'il ya d'ouvreur même très
star qu'il avait demandé we madonna
willow peur d'autres gens il n'a pas
voulu il n'a pas voulu parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui montre quand même très
très star aux états unis mais qui a
besoin de travailler avec des gens dont
ils considèrent qu'ils ont des messages
lui ces messages avaient déjà eu des
messages le personnel mais en tout cas
dans la musique lui a trouvé qu'il y
avait un message d'amour clean en fait
une espèce ducati bien qu'il dise qu'il
a séduit c'est un peu un rêve du feng
shui fonds qui manque c'est pour dire
excellent petit mais ça y est vous êtes
les soutenir